picture the guy who wrote this song
everybody what's going on welcome to
Monday melee you guys can clap welcome
our special guest today Brent Morin from
undateable we're very excited we're
gonna tell me you know him we're gonna
have the whole cast here rotating in and
out as we play various Nintendo games
during the day just another somebody
good to see a shady B's music you never
watched it you've heard of it a few
times that's right oh [ __ ]
one thing is super exciting season
premiere this Friday at 8:00 on NBC it's
all live this season all live just like
this since the 80s just like just like
this and it's not gonna be all video
games too so it's literally gonna be it
is all this idea yeah this is well yeah
it's you know I'm dead undateable melee
undateable melee exactly uh so we're
gonna play some Mario cuz you're not a
big gamer I'm not good at games so this
is get frustrated this what do you mean
you get frustrated well I'm very
competitive but I'm not good at games so
it's like I'll probably just call like
this game stupid if I lose I have to
find a way to convince myself it's not
my fault it's not gonna be it won't be
your fault you can it's you I don't
think you mean no no I know you just no
no you just can just I can do it that
way yeah you just do it this way Brent's
got the strap on for safety yeah I want
just cuz I throw a safety I don't I
don't know what all this stuff well
that's how you pick you can pick your
different vehicle they're cool exactly
this one exactly is this resin evil no
darkwing duck it's Mario Kart 8 you look
cool yup by the way if you have dating
questions Brent your guy
undateable I am it's great you do a lot
of singing on the show you just I do
these I'm I'm a good singer for a
comedian good or you're a great a joke
teller for a singer either way either
way it's it's that seems like a really
fun show to work on because it feels
like you guys are all friends and you
know yeah yeah known each other for 11
years soldier that's not moved out here
that's crazy yeah how did you D'Elia
first meeting at the haha cafe doing
stand-up comedy
really
yeah and what did you what first
impressions he hosted and he killed yeah
and I was really bad in a teenager and
insecure and so then I do tell and I was
kind of mad in my head being like you
were good I am yeah and then we kind of
looked each other Bart he has a natural
resting face is very angry this guy's
killer wanted to talk to each other but
both of us thought the other person
hated each other for no reason
wait why do you have a resting face
that's angry no you show your face quick
I feel like it's a resting face is just
like I hate life that's what I thought
that's clear rest even I think you want
to go trigger or you oh gee [ __ ] it's
like to to to is yeah hold down to right
and then right you got it
what's up with this no turning pin and
does that move that move if you do you
can like slide around corners if you
hold it yeah I'm saying hey direction
buttons supposed to work why doesn't
this work how do you turn just turn just
turn with it I think can you also do I
was it because of this no no I know it
here let's just switch turn around just
hold the mushroom you know now you're
this guy you're gonna be the guy on the
left now what you're this guy the left
oh no you trigger and trigger yeah you
can do that's on you dude it doesn't
move that's that's on you if you waited
don't stop the game you kid you have to
teach the people I'll look at them uh-oh
there it is
yeah here we go oh you know what you
have to actually turn it with the thing
you are doing this I don't I don't
actually you don't know this oh oh that
works for you for me I have to actually
turn it with this and I'm going back
what's going on with my wheels
this is crow sideways because we're
underwater that helps yeah yeah there
and you're going up the thing then they
drowned pure rage what they drown I
think I don't think you I think we like
breathe underwater
I don't know we're not I know but I
don't always like to see in a video game
is when you have the
to die in a videogame I would like to
see a very slow and realistic death yeah
like what's tomorrow I can feel bad for
them no I think we'll help Society look
at that how do i I'm flying
how do i that's crazy I'm waiting
immediate rage yes exactly I told you
I'm not gonna stir something I get
frustrated I have to scream so but
electrics and water can't be Goods this
game day yeah exactly these are electric
carts going into water a shadow that
make sure that's a very good point I
think you're going backwards I think
that's backwards what I mean I'm going
backwards am i I might not be
controlling this guy see did you see how
hard it is wait a second oh I was
looking at the wrong thing the entire
time what you thought you were me huh I
told you the right thing and then I was
like oh I'm the guy in the left - why
because I'm doing so good yeah you are
you're doing very well watch this watch
this kite kite just ran into a banana
peel what is that what I know I gotta be
honest I don't trust the mushroom guy in
this what do you mean which mushroom guy
the little of the top toad toad law note
didn't know that was his name so I
definitely don't like that yeah I think
it's a girl I think toad some girl
either way oh that I definitely yeah
don't trust women all right here's a
cure day here's an unspoken ice a
question very quickly mm-hmm are you
tired of a junkets people asking you
like dating advice and does that just
drive you insane at this point it does
because it's not what the show is about
screwed with the title the bride exactly
she's about a group of friends basically
who murdered that was a it did yes
that's what friends was they just didn't
show the murder I did like the idea of
doing a completely dramatic episode like
treat it like a drama and not tell
anybody
well just yeah and just when people
watch it like there's like don't tell
the live audience and it's so seriously
uncomfortable laughter though I'm so I'm
sick the test results came back and it's
so sad and real I think I'll be so funny
sitcom do something sodium
this is without warning Oh toda is no
reproductive organs Sisk washer is that
why he can you know I go how do you know
I don't trust toad and also how do you
know that yeah and I guess the toad is
in because I told it always smiles yeah
I don't trust somebody who never has a
frown but it's not like a genuine smile
it's like a yeah it's what I'm worried
about
yeah certain I know people like that
never trust anybody who smiles all the
time because other people they're them
we're gonna kill them so so back says
I'd like to imagine that toads get to a
ripe old age and just split into two
young toads I'm gonna like that guy that
would be better for me honestly with
girls if I just turn split into two
rather than trying to have sex with them
it'd just be like all right oh it's
Saturday night you know like freaky and
then take myself out to a movie or
something I would always like to go on a
date wearing sweats and but have but
take her like you want to come over for
a drink and she's kind of like no no and
I make her pay half but I have a castle
it's so nice it's so big so many rooms
and it's so bad I have so many rooms and
but there's really nothing in the rooms
with no TV I don't have a drink and I go
I'll be back in one minute and then I
never come back and I mean go to bed and
never come back just a claw just to see
how long she'd stay cuz I think they'll
be fine
and you lock the bedroom door yeah she's
like and she wouldn't know anyway cuz
there's so many bedrooms three bears not
like big bears bears we're the Bears I'm
rich I'm just buying bears and [ __ ] like
the the exotic pets if you have mine
like not Cubs where you're kind of like
cute but kind of like in the middle way
turning in the teenagers you're like
haha okay penguin do I have to get rid
of these because it's kind of scary now
goodbye this is sounding more and more
like the next Hunger Games movie well I
think it'd be funny just to have bears
in the house you know I always said what
I would love to do in my life yeah is
throw a Super Bowl party send out
invitations like and it looks like this
is gonna be the very Super Bowl party
ever have that castle you know people
come over on playing piano in the lobby
so big no I'm honestly can I say this
one anyways silk robe naked penis soft
plain
yeah and they're like Brent what are you
doing where's the TV and I go I don't
own a TV and then I keep playing and
don't respond to any of them and there's
no snacks there's a few carrots a plate
but just really pissed and then I hire
valet to when they park and they go to
valet the valet takes all their cars
away and like just take some and sell
them I just think something funny about
being so rich and being the meanest
person ever maybe like how was the party
honestly this is the nicest house I've
ever seen and it was the worst
experience of my life he's lost his mind
and then I'll always wear a captain's
hat and have a boat and I would take
girls on the boat and I would sleep with
him and then I jump off the boat and
Friday gets short but I leave the boat
going and she's nervous but she also has
the boat she'll be all right and then I
have to struggle to find a way back you
know so I it's a lot on me like I don't
know how I'll end up like but you know I
think that's what I want my life watch
on datable October 9th all live episodes
that's right and also Brett Prince Brett
I just called you Brett I've known you
for like five years at least five Brent
definite special December first
watch you two from one of their bits why
that's so many bear bits and silk robes
and you were great you were great you
want my creation 11:00 and like my dad
says it it's not first all right all
right that was great
Brent was way better than he thought
that's actually Kanye Tuesday
kanya Tuesdays I love it
Gingrich says that sounds like a new
reality show captain castaway exactly
let's play some Mario maker what do you
guys say play some Mario maker so here's
what we're gonna do like we did last
time we played Mario maker
hit us with some codes if you
a level you like or you just know of a
level that you enjoy hit us with some
codes and we're gonna try to get through
them I saw a great one on YouTube
somebody had made one it was called Euro
monster and it was the only way to get
through it was to kill like 30 Yoshi's
but then this guy figured out a way to
go through without killing any oshi's
and beat the game and then he was just
like fu I did it like it was awesome
t-shirt today because of undateable is a
shirt that of me being undateable so
drugs not hugs don't touch me there we
go
should we make a game should we make a
level first no let's play do you have
any codes mister some codes off off
we'll put one up hallo just a bit sure
absolutely but if we're gonna do a halo
edition we'll probably play with you
guys so and we'll put that up go to
course world yeah if you're just joining
us we're gonna have the costume
undateable coming in and out all Monday
melee it's gonna be super fun as they
finish their scenes with production and
go on break they're spending their break
with us and with you so that's very
exciting okay so here we go I think
where do we put in the thing again
anyone remember of course world run
course world global refresh
oh here we go search yep alright can be
with the first code alright this one is
from awful alright fawful da - 9 d a -
nine zero zero zero zero alright all the
zeros again 0 0 for e 0 0 9 9 f here we
go there's on u fawful if this is
terrible
there we go play
I love it that's right
hey grouchy dude good morning ooh here
we go what did you I gotta say I'm not
terrible that was just dumb I wasn't
paying attention
there's I will say it Super Mario maker
oh boy I there are I'm not super
familiar with the Mario universe so I'm
just seeing stuff I've never seen before
in my life
coinage here also I'm terrible at this
good lord good-evening Steckle perfect
so far I've done absolutely nothing
everyone's gonna get so mad at me do
grouchy dude yeah sometimes Conan stops
by sometimes he doesn't hopefully I'll
come by today unless you shootin
something there we go kill myself again
I'm just getting warmed up okay I'm just
getting warmed up you could easily beat
me shady no problem I'm terrible at
every game that's the secret of clueless
gamer you guys I'm also clueless
just take a look at what's going on here
you guys even get what they want to see
you getting punched well it's gonna have
I'll put you guys up fits it I'm at my
lecture hall watching you Blaine you're
more entertaining thank you
I'm ugliness but I like it some people
think when do we say bladder we're
saying Blaine which makes more sense cuz
Blaine is actually a name or bleh is not
[Music]
these weird these weird flying mouths
are really freaking me out
jumping socks that's correct
I'm not drunk or high enough to handle
this game good work Blaine this is a bag
thanks guys we've created a Blaine
monster how are we gonna do this there
we go hey good to see you it's all
downhill from there how do we do this
part do we oh it's not what I want to do
to get past this probably right nope
glad I did that great tip pass I'm just
reading with it I'm Justin says do a
magic trick please you know what
actually I ran to my friend Ben this
weekend and he did this crazy magic
trick and I want to know if anybody here
knows how to do it he bends his kind of
bends a kind of guy who knows like all
these weird little fun party tricks to
entertain people with and he did this
thing where he was like give me what was
it he was like give me you can walk in
those dudes if you're in the shoe sock
thing all right so I gotta get this
she's like me uh where he was like all
right give me two numbers I was like
okay and then he added them he's like
give me three numbers and he like
multiply that he's like give me another
two numbers and then at the end he was
like it was like a long a huge long
number any and it was I called it it was
his phone number which was crazy but
then we
did it again and it was random numbers
and hey how's it going you can see I'm
on it come on in everybody
oh god here you sit in the middle aisle
scissor punches what's going on say hi
to the chat everybody Rick Glassman Ron
Funches we are but do you want to play
Nintendo land instead no oh hell no let
me take off my swim I love really you
don't know any of the codes on matter
can you yeah I can find oh dude fine
uh everybody rock classical undateable
whatever you are dude do you want to try
to make it through this this level yeah
so this is oh this is interesting
yeah yeah yeah yeah take your time take
your time for goodness sakes you guys
have the pro controller are you just
working with this I mean we have we also
have the pro controller over here that
we can hook up is that easier for you I
mean it's just me what do you I don't
like this
no did you read all right let's find I'm
gonna do this oh yeah
[Music]
I love it I love it I mean I'm just
representing myself that's good do I
died I've died uh it's one of ours a big
one more than running it's crazy here we
go if we can it'll let us do it
so what's the deal Ron you made levels
yeah you're a game gamer I've seen you
post up I've no idea what you were
talking about this is explain that this
game is great right let's go to your
levels I want you to play my level all
right all right let's see if we can do
this you guys we just had Brenton here
and I just found out the new season is
undateable it starts on Friday it's all
lie yeah man how do you think you're not
statement of course feel because this is
lie yeah I guess we're failing so much
right now so I can only imagine that
Ron's levels will be a metaphor for a
better script exactly are you and how is
that change the way you guys are
approaching the season obviously more
rehearsals right I think so or no did
you guys rehearse the scenes and stuff
before yeah we always whatever man
whatever you think we'd best for me as
an introduction to this there we go
there we go um be easy I might be easy I
think that the main thing if anything is
different is a few more rehearsals but
just um instead of writing alternate
jokes
us the performers I think we're spending
a little bit more time figuring out how
to recover from failure Oh interesting
interesting nothing is messed up like
what kind of jokes do we do in case
things don't go as planned as opposed to
assuming that oh that citrus users got
another tape do you have can you share
some of those strategies are even
strategy yeah I when I mess up should me
if when I there we go that's yeah that's
right I'm going to just look into the
camera and yell rah it's all on you it's
all your shoulders you're the emotional
hatless you're the emotional app we link
that up
yeah let's link it up let's link it up
let's find out how to do that Ron I
should have assumed that you would do a
big mushroom first Oh what is this my
goal I don't know if I like that hipster
Mario jumps higher I don't want question
Mario okay all right Ron you were just
high when you made this huh
I read these things don't even exist
these things don't even fit
I mean you created mushrooms all right
give you a better remote Oh hold on
we're trying for the pro controller
we're trying to get the pro controller
set up which is great I mean there's I'm
picturing Bowser's gonna have your face
playing do you think that's the problem
[Music]
rod what so what's your strategy Ron if
you screw up I don't plan there we go
that's what I'm talking about that's the
kind of to do you want from well my
comedy on accidental failure Oh their
failure but I've been selling it as an
accident there we go
so we're different strategies with this
okay okay I got past everything even
said man give me a superintendent or a
Nintendo controller next we have that
you want one of these would you rather
play this this with crazy disco I would
rather that than what I'm using right
now but I would rather a yeah give me
that this is like playing you're playing
with like a dinner plate right no that's
that's kind of a spinner but that's
basically an NES controller yes this is
true okay oh this is the one this is the
one fried there's no turbo because I'm
trying to switch let's switch
thanks which we're gonna go out let's
see if we can play with that yeah oh
there we go
where is no excuses now yeah could we
switch be an ex or something settings
for real though will be maybe hit no
beach beam a jump X&Y turbo we can do
that that's a good question how do we
can we go in - hold on we're going deep
into submenus everybody deep this is
gonna change a lot of things for here we
go she's just I mean no you're an expert
I love it it's crazy there we go come
out with super because everybody had
been modding their levels forever anyway
I mean it's you know about is how easy
it is to make levels and it's fun to
make love I didn't think I was gonna
make any little bumble see Ron is demand
yo I love it I love it
watch out babe that's right I think I
got enough for real I'm happy don't get
neopixel unlocking the secrets of the
options menu exactly Ron's like our
shaman guy through this sub menus
Nintendo rod what's your secret
you know this looking in the book yeah I
read the book that's provided for me
when I purchased the game that's awesome
so it has to be exciting to be to be
live which is cool but also you guys are
all we're talking about I was talking
about this with Brent but you guys kind
of are all friends and joke around
anyway which must make it easier as well
these you have confidence in each other
I got a could you have run or some of
the other guys oh yes I never mind I was
gonna ask if you gave me another star
[Music]
okay well done Wow Roberts your strategy
for making game what do you like maybe
what make I don't complicated the
hardest one yet you know I didn't notice
my favorite you know what I noticed one
of your strategies and making a game is
that could tell from your frustrations
of one losing a lot but to being able to
work hard and wanting to get better is
making the level somewhat difficult but
making sure one of the first things you
get is an extra life so you have
basically it's called the unlimited
quarters technique oh I like that that's
okay it is you know I have to say it
it's kind of weird there was a shift I
feel like maybe five or six it doesn't
matter where you fall okay understand
the rhythms five six usually go to games
that now don't have lives now it's kind
of just like yeah oh yeah there you go
you got to give them tips games don't
have lives anymore you know now it's
just like it just continued like forever
whoa but if it's like minutes okay
I gotta learn the babies I got it out
exactly
whoops did make that cat tail boy show
you that was several years ago having
done so many things is been very good
why did it not work further every time
don't get comfortable
is this for you guys is undateable the
first to come you guys have been on yeah
well may I did like a guest role on new
girl okay but before other than that
this was the first thing that I did and
so now this is your second season we
head into Thursday 3 and how are you
guys still learning like what what's
something you learned last season that
was kind of surprising
um learn how to relax more and doing the
live episodes just learning that be
confident you're not learning anything
it's eating over here you see them you
just put all these these special little
mid guys just in one little row because
you have the availability of it he's
getting in your head right off the bat
yeah alright but if there's one thing
that I don't do twice it's make the same
mistake
[Music]
please best outfits are always on point
respect I fell could I not shoot them
you can't shoot them but you don't have
to there we go thank you I love it how
is the decision made to do a whole
season of live emphasis basically they
were like hey do you want to keep the
show on the air we don't make the
decision yeah were you guys consulted at
all about it we just like yeah just like
hey we might do another live one and
then they were like hey we're gonna do a
more alive
they're like except like Rick says no
and so they just pre take adjust your
parts so they turn to you and your self
hologram all these races phases grace
two races but somehow in every screw up
it works
[Laughter]
I love it hey chica Phoenix what's up
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is it go to school play runescape
you know what's interesting to me is
that in your world run you could get a
Oh
[Music]
heartbreaker heart on a guaranteeing a
win a heart bring this round I did a
good job it's constant danger if there's
ever been criticism of Ron it has not
been the flow of his video creations
love it rock what are you what are you
playing besides this game I'm playing
mostly Metal Gear Solid 5 oh nice but I
kind of like if I don't if I stop for a
little bit and then I kind of get out of
it which is where I'm at now yeah so I'm
trying to get back into it
yeah but I'm wrong playing that blame
this I'm waiting for the new WWE game
Halo 5 nice oh yes I real a little Ron
in a Bridget come out I mean obviously
I'm comforting clear there time for one
more round or they got a run they got a
ride hey okay set me up with it yeah one
not whole level let me just try it one
super competitive now I like it
all you guys seem very competitive I
[Laughter]
mean that's what makes the show really
good is that we only trying to find the
best jokes and trying to beat each other
with yeah but also just help each other
hopefully anything yeah for real like we
always want to be the funniest and try
to beat each other but if anyone has a
better idea for a joke they give it run
gives me so many jokes that's awesome
that's really cool Ron what do I give
you it's still going still going it's
still going man I can't wait long this
level is you guys don't do dank memes
kids stay in school
that's what I say all right well watch
you all fall out I can't wait I got to
pip-boy edition ordered Oh
whichever one gets the better reviews
I'll be selling the other
Oh
Titan a spa the new WWE just is not
gonna have Hogan in it how do you feel
good for too long do nerds watch this
stuff yes do if anybody has any power 9
Magic the Gathering cards
yeah and or sealed alpha beta or
unlimited booster packs or starter decks
again I'm in season 3 so I am in the
market and I'm looking for again any
power 9 alpha beta unlimited sealed
starters I love our boosters I don't
even know exact match ik what are we
talking I said gathering what I don't
need a fire flower ok
maybe yeah oh my god will do some magic
the gathering next time I have a
blue-white deck from back in the day I
wonder if any of those cards are worse I
wanna I've been wanting to do twitch at
home I don't know oh dude oh I
understand I have a job well set you up
I'm really bright me absolutely man so
Holly help me with my home setup it's
awesome relieved we're going tell them
that Ron made the level 2 hardness is
falling follow me I'll make more levels
if I do comedy and acting but my true
passion is Mario levels yeah what's your
what's your I can people find your Mario
maker level what are you yeah I think I
just call myself me which isn't good
probably for people to follow me
let me go my Instagram there we go
through and every time I upload a level
I love it so I love it my right punches
are run fun run funk there we go and and
Rick where are you on what do you
request no I can't even put the clouds
are too small yeah Rick Glassman is my
social media Twitter Instagram all that
I love it I love it thank you so much
fun having this is great oh my god
school absolutely twitch alright
undateable this Friday
please play my place bro one one time
have five up I'll make some more I'll
make eight and then I'll switch over to
a new style but also watch undateable
thank you guys thank you wallet oh yeah
[Music]
alright alright let's try to beat Ron's
level here we go alright oh man this is
gonna be rough
we got to do round right exactly man
love those guys
Ricky Ron the best and bread as well and
again yes watching dateable on Friday
and evil aha
I think Rick I think was trying to take
it too fast I'm gonna take a little
slower here Oh God extra pressure I
don't know what you did to the levels
maker right yeah I know exactly exactly
exactly
hashtag do Ron right I don't know how
did he oh I see
did he make the he change it so what is
this turbo did he change the turbo on me
I think he did no he did sweet that's
now I just got a match buttons all right
let's just do it here we go
we go oh man this is rough how do we do
this
oh there we go I didn't even I was the
problem is I wasn't paying attention
oh man I gotta get that there we go
wow you can make a cannon that shoots
fireball after that guy you can make a
cannon that shoots fireball flowers I
gotta get up there he changed the turbo
on me so now it's hard for me to enjoy
your class stay in school kids dank
memes saying just say no to dank meme
for you guys he's right that that cloud
is just a one too far
Oh King Crimson you're right we should
have played Halloween games but here's
what happened we thought all the
attainable guys were to come at once
meaning we're gonna have to find a five
player game so I was gonna play Nintendo
I'm sorry about that let's go play
Nintendo land about five of us but now
they came and now they're just coming
kind of one and two when ones and twos
and we had already Oh God
son of a so that's why we we were gonna
play skagens we won't play scary games
next week for sure no no no oh man
lunches make some tough levels I looked
it up Anna dank meme is an ironic
expression used to walk online viral
media and in jokes that have exhausted
their comedic value God it's so tender
so dank memes are something people say
when they're tired of seeing means it's
dank hey what's up hey guys wanna come
on in here we go today are to the
chatter
everyone oh my god all right so we're
playing one of punches have you ever
played super mark are you a gamer
let's start it let's start at the
beginning no but when I was a kid I
played this a lot okay great right
alright so this is a game called Super
Mario maker a guy can make your own
Super Mario levels we're playing one of
ron funches levels okay did he make that
just now or does he make it he made it
earlier he's made a bunch of levels he's
very excited about it we're trying to
hashtag do Ron right by beating his
level okay so that's what you're
stepping it to right okay and this is
everybody in the chat right here
hello everyone hey Jake do Ron right
there we go okay I'll try
a beard man yes they're a see would its
to be R its beard men think yeah I love
it so you want to try to play sure all
right here we go I'm about to die there
we go all right hard it's very hard but
I've been dying a lot I'm gonna be
totally fine be totally fine good stuff
perfect but you're exactly like me like
me okay I love it alright okay Susu book
says hello David hi there's a bum yo-yo
yes Lumberjacks play video games we we
Lumberjacks in the forest what are the
guns
um big there we go you got your shooting
today right or not shoot EB or are you
rehearsing and all that stuff we're
rehearsing yeah I love it
I've been asking everybody this but how
do you feel about a whole season of live
episode I feel really good about it I
think it just kind of um it keeps us on
our toes yeah and it makes us do better
acting right absolutely and a nice to do
oh yeah go go go because David game
real-life depends who's asking
yeah I just died that's all right I'm no
I'm married to a woman there we go
but I have kissed men there we go and it
might happen right now between us I'm
feeling us there's a tension this this
this air is getting hot it's too many
bad there's so much too much bad for
them not to be sexually just attracting
each other okay if I get any further
than I have before
exactly do you want it would you rather
play a driving game like Mario Kart Oh
I let me just try and get a little bit
further
all you all the indeed able guys are
really competitive it's hilarious yeah
Rick was getting seething anger ease
meeting Rick Rick Rick very competitive
at Ron Ron made the level and Rick was
yelling on it was great um we were
talking about for this season yeah do
you have a strategy if something goes
wrong when it's live just don't curse is
the only strategy okay okay we can find
something like I think it's seven
million dollars that's so many dollar
it's so many but that's an actual amount
that's real seven million dollars wait
is it oh my gosh that's crazy so Brent
who says [ __ ] and [ __ ] after usually in
any scene a break he'll break and say
[ __ ] in [ __ ] multiple times
oh my god Lord but I can say I can say
British curse words like what what are
some like it would like like nagging is
not a British curse word it's not really
a curse snogging
no no just kissing alright so bollocks
bollocks Aras is a good one
wanker wankers like jerk off yeah who's
gonna win the Premier League I'm a Man
United fan but I think man says you're
gonna win it this year there we go
I love it so you can sell this and you
won't get fine all I could find you oh
you're golden for me that's like I can I
can say that right exactly oh you're
going lately suck at this so you you
could just work in swears the entire
episode young friends face basically
yeah yeah just call him a wanker and I
do that anyway British it's thought
sweet when he says that JD's in she's
England that's gone there we go
she said yes teach them are slash felons
a good one cos they Bend is a good one
go man City my boy
who's a man city fan action Jackson 552
someone say can you say the c-word no I
think if your announcer Mongolia Fannie
Fannie is a good one Danny Fanny means
we just drop it
that's not a real thing do I let my
granny's wet or crispy what he brought
me Angie
oh no so what's calling you a trainer
because a man United how am i trade
sales I've always supported them there
we go well the most accessible British
Club of all time that's a is that now
why are you mean you know fit or is that
did you grow up as of me yeah I come
from an Irish family and my uncle he
used to play for a big club in Ireland
used to know George best and George best
is pretty much there he's Welsh curses
all right but what's happenin I buddy
that's Welsh the well should just beat
the English at the rugby so they're all
buzzing the world Shiv got a song when
it comes to rogue bass as long as we
beat the English I have to say like
football has rivalries like no like no
other sport they are serious if you go
to Glasgow and you to sell ticking again
strangers yes the Derby there that's
probably the most intense sporting
rivalry I'd say in the world
wow they ain't doing run right right now
I'm not I'm talking about football
that's why do you actually switch let's
change let's change it up let's change
it up favorite Harry Potter character
[Music]
favorite character the domhnall gleeson
whoever he plays well don't look don't
listen if he plays a Weasley brother oh
there we go then we things are great I
visit did you read the books no I'm not
big I wasn't a fan of the books of Harry
Potter but I really liked the films yeah
yeah the films are incredible huge he
names is sometimes depends mostly maybe
that's a name of Ron's thing that's runs
Sam oh no no this isn't we're out of
Ron's thing yo Dave do I think Oasis
would ever get back together probably
not although they were my favourite band
and I was growing up oh there we go
yeah favorite bear now my favorite by
now Fat Freddy's Drop I'm still in my
love affair for them hasn't change but
he's fat Freddy's there a reggae band
from news
there we go everybody cool how do you
find new music are you looking at
Spotify with your do i amö Spotify yeah
but I like to go to kind of shitty gigs
yeah just random like he'll be like
you'll check it out yeah like I found
mattis yar and although he's huge here
now but like twelve years ago some
shitty gig in in London my friend was
Jewish rapper let's go see yeah it was
mattis yahoo and then he just like blew
up yeah that hit us with a dealer code a
fan code we're gonna play we're gonna
play your code favorite doctor from
Doctor Who would be me because I worked
with him at Smith because I did today
sir oh you Doctor Who yeah oh my god I
was in the Pandorica opens episode holy
crap wait oh my god that here's why I
love oh well this is gonna be huge
this is gonna ruin it for everybody but
I love the twist of the pander go like
you know cuz they're trying to figure
out what it is is what it is and then
when he finally figures it out it's
awesome that's amazing yeah like oh yeah
it's so great
wow that's crazy I don't know the geeky
British shows I did what was your what
we're luck as well and Game of Thrones
and were you are why why does this
person keep telling me to put my jacket
away because it's covering my crotch
yeah exactly so I get a boner for the
game what are you a huge fan of geeky
British shows and so got where was it
weirdly stars was really small I was so
I won I just Sherlock I was more excited
at finding out what happened when he
fell off the building yes absolutely
than actually getting the job I was more
excited at having the knowledge before
my you literally like MIT that was the
whole reason why you became an actor and
just just to literally try to do that
boil things for your friends did I study
acting at uni yes I did that's ours can
I sit on your face though probably how's
that gonna work I was saying they were
underlying my boner yeah give me a
minute
exactly hit us with a code Beth please
this one's real 420 420 420 now that's
not real exactly Oh Jeff Pfeffer says we
still don't even know what happened in
Sherlock where you jumped off the
building
I'd rather have 10 dicks or no dick it
depends on where the dicks are yeah if
it is it finger dicks is it yeah are you
talking like Edward penis hands or is it
more are they all like in a row on your
arm it's like a fringe jacket you know
like here here's actually a question
would you rather have I love I preface
this by here's actually a question one
giant toe on each foot yeah or ten toes
on each foot because it's wheat because
here's the thing one toe you could hide
easier oh yeah see but you can't wear
flip-flops yeah and how are you gonna
cut that giant I mean it's got a nail on
it too like a huge toenail like this
yeah yeah or ten little toes I'd say ten
little toes because I think that would
give you like superhuman agility oh
right that's a good point you know I'd
even think about that you're more like
spider-man you could no one could ever
knock you over yeah exactly yeah because
you just your toes would be yeah yeah
yeah you have and then you could
probably honest you could probably cut
those extra toes off like what are we
even talking about yeah if you just have
one giant toe on each foot how can you
what are you gonna do there you're
screwed having a toe dick yeah
hashtag toe dick exact Oh dick there is
a hashtag for it bad headers are the
code okay okay
would you rather fight one out sighs
chicken a hundred chickens like today
that's a coating I'm you know what I
really want them to make is a tiny
elephant like I want scientists to make
like an elephant that's like this yeah
like a micro pig yeah I know it probably
ruined like whatever the earth or the
cause you can't introduce new animals
yeah you know me Jurassic Jurassic Park
taught us nothing
you know later life lines the web
what did you think of any dress apart by
the way ah didn't see it go ah do you
see it what do you think well the
original is my favorite from all time oh
wow yeah oh my god only because of what
it did for me when I was a kid but of
course do you want to try do you want me
to give a stab at it first I watched you
all right and read the Casey this is how
good I am by the way so you have to
understand like someone sucks more than
me oh I suck so bad it's terrible what's
my favorite comedy at the office the
original Englishman David Brent yeah so
amazing oh that show the second season
of the office the British office is like
an emotional submarine it just keeps
getting you're like oh my god one of my
favorite moments of Elmo any TV show
ever is when he comes in dressed as his
boss and with the shoe just he's got a
cheap jacket oh just the best it's just
[Laughter]
we've been are you now have you
obviously like being on a table all
these tumors hose you man it you've met
so many amazing actors yeah I did have
you ever been starstruck yeah I did
life's too short
oh wow oh my god you got to meet Ricki
yeah yeah how was it it was incredible
because he's so nice really yeah yeah
he's so nice because you know this kind
of the thing he did at the Golden Globes
that's just him having fun that's a
pleasure actually my the best moment of
my probably of my any acting I've ever
done was um he directed me in the
seniors life and at the end of this you
just want to look straight down the
camera just like you're kind of annoyed
at what's just happened you know like we
did in the office and then I did it and
as I did it he was in another room on
the monitors and I was just like I'm
done oh that's awesome
nice Team Coco follow me on Twitter
David fern f1n RIT who's that are you on
Instagram also I'm on Instagram Dave
Levin FY and then three ends fyn and I
just joined periscope an hour ago
oh my god we've started periscoping our
commercial breaks oh cool which is
really fun
periscope is interesting because it's
like you can there's you can do anything
like yeah the bar is very low they just
want to see you and yeah and talk to you
I'm think I mean I know people have
probably done this already but I'm
thinking of a periscope - Oh periscope
there we go I have no idea how to get
down here
what's up with this level man I'm not on
snapchat no snap just [ __ ] snapchats
frightens me
it's too private people kind of behave
themselves when they're in public I said
if I ever had the chance to meet Sir
Patrick Stewart I haven't but I've
started to thing called hashtag
15-second Shakespeare and we're waiting
for him to do one whoa wait wait wait
sit sitting at 15 check instincts for
what is I started a thing last week or
15 second Shakespeare okay and it's just
basically doing [ __ ] pop songs but in a
really dramatic Shakespeare start oh I
did Fresh Prince of bel-air are you
treasure your Shakespearean trained
actor yeah yeah yeah but this is ask
this is me just having a bit of rest so
I did a rap from Fresh Prince of Bel Air
but really intense yes so then like
Michael Sheen's done 100 guys from
Flight of the Conchords has done one
awesome and we're just waiting on
Patrick scripted to do his wow that's
awesome yeah because that will just
that's cool
yeah great Thomas Middleditch oh he's
he's the best he's yeah I met Stephen
Merchant on the same thing very close
gamers the GTA one oh yeah we do that we
do a thing called clueless gamer where
we play a video games together if you
want to try it so this is ridiculously
hard I don't know I I think you know
what I think it is is I think we're
suffering for the fact that everyone is
really good at this game is except for
us so for other people this is like oh
it's not that hard I think you just
gotta go up what just pret dog oh god
the ghosts oh I thought they were
friendlies no oh my god
all right well Davidson's thank you
undateable live Friday
NBC 8 o'clock follow him at David FY N
and N on Instagram Instagram and then
- ends on Twitter just to n2 ends on the
Twitter 3 on Instagram and fit a hashtag
15-second Shakespeare thank you I'm just
joining exactly our beards wanted it
there we go oh and one for the chat one
for the chat I love it thank you say
thank you I love it did Rick kiss you no
no but now I'm gonna go over to your
second kiss everyone passed that kiss
along to them for me love it oh if beard
is so soft our beards touched it was
amazing I was hoping me and David food
kiss and that's oh my god wait a second
those lips possibly I know you're dying
you're dying right now
you're dying he was in the Pandorica
opens I wasn't I recognized him from
that that's crazy that is that's
absolutely great over here like there's
just a slow puddle of urine
spreading around Beth if she realizes
who David Finn is that's great Oh see
how we should've waited till I got down
there there we go
well I've made it past the first part of
this I do I will say like I think it's
awesome that undateable is doing a whole
live season because that's the thing is
like now there's so much great TV I
think it's very hard to kind of separate
yourself out so and that's awesome I
mean it's obviously a lot of work doing
a lot of show look at SNL but the
rewards are great because there's like
some kind of energy you know what I'm
saying that you get you get doing
something live that you just don't get
otherwise
obviously look at what we're doing right
now it's pretty fantastic Brendan Joe
peace that was David Finn from oh and I
messed up and now I'm dead
that was David Finn from undateable I
just have to kill myself now right guys
punch f man your garbage stop playing
thank you
exactly Beth needs a kiss she's feeling
left out cream shared thank you yeah I
feel like I've been kissed without
exactly exactly she was close enough to
the beard where she got that who's Ian
black mirror what episode I have to see
the second season by the are though
oh my god no we didn't forget about you
YouTube
[Music]
hey Kappa Deez Nuts what's up I love it
do you have anyone else stopped you my
Ruth here now all right great
thank you guys the undateable guys for
stopping by today that was fantastic and
again please if you're watching tweet at
us your Mario maker levels then we could
be prepared for next time I feel like we
might have played before
[Applause]
exactly
hey comedy duh Chad to show us angsty
teens a good time we're trying dude I'm
trying to show you guys a good time
oh but Mario maker is awesome I feel
like Brent actually is way better
videogames then he gives himself credit
for I saw him at a Mortal Kombat
tournament which is a nerdy thing to say
but whatever and he I think got to the
finals where he played Wayne Brady was
very there's a crazy mix of people there
that was great
there we go this is what I'm game
someone's asking bleh if they meet you
can they kiss ya
no I don't kiss anybody you have to be
on Doctor Who Sherlock and black mirror
to kiss me sorry is what it is that's
that's the standards I've set for myself
I have to say Mario music is some of my
favorite it's like ingrained into my DNA
like this music it's crazy that's a good
question yeah I think I think you can
pick the music
I love it ah Z great damn this guy is
bad you're right I'm really bad maybe I
should play something else doesn't
feelin me on this you could also kiss
Lindsay Duncan whoa great let's get her
on Monday mail a second kisser this just
becomes a thing of me trying to kiss
people who have been on British shows
what is that that's what that's what
Monday mailing becomes there are no more
guests today yeah no more guests today
sorry guys I do really want to play
Nintendo land cuz it's really fun let's
play let's play this was fun but I just
I had my heart set on it today I'm glad
all those guys came and thanked you for
for coming but I was looking forward to
a full cash today cranium can I kiss you
since I play video games um sure fine
that's all it takes really at this point
in my life at this point in my life
nope nope here we go on the tender land
I love new tender land this is great are
you gonna play that it's gonna be kind
of it that's right well you want to play
Nintendo land
O'Malley one planet in DeLand it's
really easy all right yeah yeah we're
all gonna play at the same time all
right here we go
Jason Valley wheel backed in oh boy here
we go we're gonna play we're gonna play
a little Mario chase all right so yeah
four players five four before oh you
know what I need to where's the other
remote I need to use this one creepers
in front of the camera oh boy game
changer
all right wait does somebody somebody's
not working
yeah everybody you got a point at the
screen
I called Graham's point at the screen no
one get grams wait
oh no I think you want here take your
thing out also you don't need to put the
strap your green you're good
you're great get it yeah
select somebody hit
guess D all right who has to pick their
person either done I want to be Gramps
you have to go then over to the other
arrow
oh no you already did pick your guy oh
you picked your guy willed you pick your
guy thought I think my guy did you wait
is it Lee oh you know what it's this one
sorry
somebody something's left up alright
alright I'll be coding oh yeah I'll be
me yes here we go
I'm not sure who's got what yes
all right I'm gonna run you guys have to
catch me okay so you're gonna turn it
sideways you're gonna turn it sideways
yeah and you're gonna turn it sideways
this way and you're gonna run like this
and then you're when you unclose you're
gonna ten did that to try that see look
yeah - is tax-favored so somebody
somebody I feel like it's gonna need to
and this it'll all work cuz there's a
next room we'll see look at the gamepad
screen laid - there we go
all money on grants somebody says yeah
there we go
thank you bye account you are oh yeah
that's you
the rules are you just try to follow me
alright
just try to get me all right you guys
gotta catch me ready oh I look good in
this by the way here we go
yeah
[Music]
you can't wreck it crayons are just
excited all right try to get me guys
there you go
[Music]
fan out I'm going right okay I'm in
yellow no one's ever gonna catch me I'm
in green I'm doing great
[Music]
never gonna catch me make somebody else
oh this is too easy you guys oh this is
so easy I'm Betty's outer track I'm
checking outer track so easy
I don't feel too attached to my guests
see uh-uh-uh-uh-uh what's happening now
any visual contact anybody can you ride
any of the stuff in the sky oh you guys
are the worst at this oh my god you guys
anyone yards away
okay they are the worst okay thanks for
the tutorial by the way yeah I know
well I'm the guy you're trying to catch
so I'm getting closer dramatically
closer I think he's in pink in red oh I
see him or not
oh my god no one's even seen me this is
great oh this is awesome
I should be a professional run away oh
you guys this is great oh I'm so
embarrassed for you can you tell it's
all just running baby's gotta get that
cardio gotta get that cardio be seconds
does anyone close no I'm the closest
I've been here you paint yeah oh yeah
you're really close you're in the
Covenant I'm a visual blue oh you guys
this is the best part cuz now we get to
see where everybody what ever needs to
play rocket League yeah yeah so they
give you a bird's-eye or any is in every
play I'm the professional invader I'm a
juke master baby check this out oh this
is great you guys weren't even close
this is fantastic look you guys rolling
where do we go I'm on the other side of
the world I double back you got no I got
no idea who is blue Oh your grant senior
kind of close somebody saw me I snuck
around look at this this is a very who
wanted to be the runner who wants me the
runner I'll be running all right
I'm out of your runner which what am i
doing I think you're chopped there yeah
all right look at that
look at that oh man all right awesome
depressing the guy with the drugs not
hugs shirt is good at running what a
surprise all right let's try yes
let's try we're gonna try new level well
there's mud everybody communicate all
right this is the key to catching
O'Malley yes yes yes yes communicate
noobs reck scrubs I love it
yes use yes Oh Vincent we're in charge
of the cone you so like 10 seconds or
something there's a maze runner this is
not yeah
this is the Scorch Trials exactly Oh God
creeper all right we see we can see your
film Ali's face yeah so look at the look
at the yardage there we go all right I'm
gonna get him down now I know about the
yardage thing yeah
also the mud sucks and went over Oh when
you run over a bridge it disappears
I mean yellow I'm headed towards green
no he's not no he's coming towards me
he's coming towards me I think I'm
headed towards green I'm burning all the
bridges I'm headed towards green now
he's running away
easy oh now he's really running away I
think he's running backwards yellow mud
stuff because you're always looking at
your yardage yeah all right
he's running away I think you might be
in red is anyone in red wait I'm getting
close I'm homing I'm Horning in on him
he's close he's really close yeah we
might be able to trap him wait wait I
think he's in blue I can't tell he's oh
I think he's in red I think he's right
now wait outside look do you see him I
think he's in red headed towards yellow
now I think he's in yellow eyes in
yellow he's so he's so wily I'm in
yellow I don't see he's I feel like he's
kind of close I feel like he's gonna be
running for the center cuz there's a oh
oh oh is that no it's you god I don't
think I've broken 50 yards
he's gonna try to get that thing and so
I see him he's a blue he said no that's
not no that's you
sorry that's you will oh that's you damn
it where is he seconds damn it I don't
have eyes anyone have eyes on target the
target I'm in green I don't think he's
in green oh I think is in blue I think
he's it blue I think he's in blue - oh I
see a piece of blue he headed towards
green blue headed towards green upper
upper deck I see him he's in red he's in
red upper deck red upper deck red upper
deck red I saw I see oh god I'm so close
he's headed towards the center son of a
[ __ ] he's headed towards green he's at
green
oh no disappeared [ __ ] he's a green he's
at green is it green he's in blue he's
in blue
[Music]
we almost had him at the end ah yeah oh
you have to celebrate muddy yeah
man in the end he almost got him I'm
terrible at call up somebody said look
at this oh you just stayed that was
interesting that's an interesting
strategy
alright let's play let's play this ghost
game before we go okay so I'm good I
just want to see the ant ah oh [ __ ] the
camera should we do the camera in the
lower right oh yeah it's a good call it
was a little chalice thanks muddy so
riders lower right yeah
oh we kind of got it at the end there
he's on the run
the mud if it wasn't mud we would have
got him I think
yeah let's play the guests one for a
professional go sir
yes so coaster here we go we got a stamp
dramatically I'm sure okay here we go
thank you again for the undateable guys
showing up oh wait wait no watch there
the season premiere of the show this
Friday day on NBC this is fun so the
same basic idea just different kind of
so this idea is with this one how's this
sorry everybody
see ya we got a point your thing at the
screen to pick the guy grabs a George I
don't play Animal Crossing no maybe I
should please stop returning videotapes
please stop referring to your viewers is
undateable I am the most unbeatable here
we go that's fine yes alright now this
one is I'm a ghost okay
and you guys have flashlights and you're
trying to burn me with the flashlight
and I'm trying to get you and I'm
invisible so you can't I'm the ghost you
got it so you can shine the light you
only have a certain amount of flashlight
the three bearded amigos III don't think
any of you guys are undateable I'm
undateable oh my god I'm dying the Conan
me that's all right
here we go
don't get freaked out guys and if
somebody dies you can revive them by
being knocked you got it yeah all right
here we go
why does sidestep warrant a button I
think it's because it just helps you
judge oh so if you touch us you kill us
yeah also if I get close to you your
thing will start vibrating does that
make sense oh it's a year your
controller will stop for anything if I
get close to you so we want to use their
flashlights sparingly yeah
oh boy sure anyone got anything are you
green
I'm ground I am I'm like Luigi colours
let's try to trap him oh gosh so we can
go in middle middle middle
oh hi tank got him oh he's stuck in here
so you can if you go over to - - Beth
you can revive her never listen to the
game save you can save us you got time
you got time turn behind you behind you
[Music]
I mean I can't attack you if you if he's
happy with the light you wanna play yeah
now that you guys got the idea guys I
tried this in YouTube chat didn't work
but back when I was in Middle School in
a chocolate bar okay uh I'm not sure
can we all change team cocoa to
something like cocoa the Conan the
comedian what I don't think we're gonna
change our brand comment but thank you
very suggestion really it is actually it
is interesting like I will say it's
interesting that ice tea's wife is also
his name cocoa also so the very
beginning like we she was also team
cocoa which is fun so the more team coca
the better here we go all right start in
the middle I started the middle yes
you'll see me disappear
Oh God someone asked how already we do
this every every Monday every Monday at
noon pacific
hope you guys are ready I embarrassed
you last time I'm coming at you
you guys don't communicate at all it's
amazing
I got nothing really all right I'm out
of this trap all right all right let's
see these over in this carrier then we
can totally yeah let's try two more mom
I'm getting I'm getting activity I think
it's over over the top right now moving
moving moving middle whose purple not on
reading work you're saying the opposite
way anything let's say bad how do I say
you gotta shine your light on her I got
burned
you got burnt what's that it's a battery
oh yeah so you can save this bird ah
yeah it's getting the hang of it no no
that's starting to twitch am I gonna
like
[Music]
oh I got bird dammit
this has become harder than I thought
I think I need a battery here I come
dammit
me versus you will here we go ah how did
you even see me the runaway
mano-a-mano he's not even trying to
revive the other people I love this well
you want to be the ghost this time
because you did so well killing me oh
sure and then we'll do a kiss our last
game what do I do
so you're just gonna look yeah you're
just gonna look at the gamepad and I
just moving yeah you just you just move
and try to get us yep circuit two you
play but you'll get to see everything on
there yeah so I'm just trying to stay
out of the light and kill you guys we
got it
deluded Raven we the coconuts appreciate
this dream you're gonna see oh you're
come to see Conan November that's cool
cheeky ghost ghost tripping boo poke
poker UFC Fan bleh do you like Conan or
Andy more good question
I'm actually a big fan of Scott Healy
I'm keyboards here we go guys I'm oh my
god this
all right I don't have any vibration oh
my god you guys this is ridiculous
bring it well where you guys ah I see
you there
yeah robot guy helps his back alright
nothing so far he's getting time for the
robot guy watch my back
got it got him oh nice burning him up
stand by this robot guy yes
okay now I understand the team that are
the teamwork bank and we got a revive on
their side he's coming for he's coming
for he's coming for me hi Gabby
Beth going for battery for me oh yeah
man he's got it
unnecessary careful Beth careful shiny
shut it
yes yes I'm Bell he's back I won't let
you guys down
I think he's coming close to me
which color you bleh oh nice I'm red
we're back all right full strength you
guys he's close let's get it let's get
him I can get me wrong
almost you owe me bad get them yes still
sighs we did it
awesome Idol it's my favorite things
that's great that's great all right guys
I think that'll do it for today thank
you so much for watching thank you the
cast of undateable David Ronn Brent and
Rick please watch undateable the season
premiere this Friday 8 o'clock on NBC
it's this season is all live so they're
calling undateable live hashtag
undateable live and follow Ron Funches
on Mario maker because he made some
great levels and thank you guys for
joining us we will see you next week
with some scary games right here on
Monday melee noon pacific see you guys
later have a great way
[Applause]
you